richard est connu pour ses coups de
gueule ses coups de tête et coups de
coeur 1 c'est bien ça alors j'ai dû
faire une interview dernier coup tu mens
jamais eu c'est lorgues var or dernier
coup de gueule justement face à ce qu'il
ya cinq minutes maintenant je vais pas
répondre tout le temps à ta place
qu'est ce que tu veux je te dis ton
dernier coup de gueule dans la vie voilà
n'ont rien à pansements un bon nom mon
profil bas profil bas ouais volontaires
difficile je te connais visible en
façade un dernier coup de coeur des
confessions d'un barjou way dans les
coups de poing
oh ya deux ans ouais ouais qu'entre qui
bat eu un mic enfin c'est d'ailleurs
c'était pas volontaire
qui sait il essayé de se raccrocher et
il a glissé plate et comme j'étais cuit
on a été déclarée match nul oui dans la
sueur les clubs mais que le torchon
c'est vachement bien il y avait un
berger allemand dans la sueur au dernier
coup de foudre ya les coups de foudre
ouais ma fille ou tel un coup de rouge
il ya 14 mois à 14 mois à la flotte
ouais t'as mais rien ça te va bien bien
six as et la coupe de cheveux non mais
c'est vrai on serait pas en public la
dernier coup droit
juin
ou bien les grains
quelques jours ouais bah c'est pas tous
les jours non et quand même jour deux
jours à mousson ouais c'est quoi trois
fois par semaine ouais mais voilà on est
au courant comme ça dans les coups de
bluff que tu as fait à je suis tellement
en dérapage au contrôle et là j'ai
inscrit le nom des mecs que je voulais
dans mon film avant de leur avoir
demandé
ouais ouais du coup ils ont été obligés
d'accepter les tapis ministre c'est du
bluff pour toi ben alors il faut laisser
faire son trou et moi j'en sais rien moi
toute façon qui dit gg tout et c'est 40
bah ouais c'est caramba tout ça non
étape il faut le laisser bosser
bon faudra bien arriver un jour je vais
te faire une interview dernier coup ok
dernier coup de coeur mon dernier coup
de coeur bat et remonte déjà à quelques
pas mal d'années pour moi il continué
oui dans les coups de poing mon dernier
coup de poing c'était à gstaad
il y avait tant un type qui m'a traitée
de sale français votent fn
un coup de folie dernier coup de folie
basse et quand je m'achète un veste
navès parvenons sa demie de patronne
mais une bagnole lamborghini
pour l'instant c'est une
une mercedes 300 sl koala que c'est bien
ouais jeta prêterait dernier coup de
gueule on le dernier coup de gueule
c'est après moi même je coince et à
placer contre moi que j'ai je veux aussi
faire le plus c'est dur avec toi même je
suis dur avec moi même pas donc pas ce
que je n'aime pas tellement et je me
fais chier je m'auto fait chier quand tu
comprendras déclin du rsta perçus
l'année coup dur dernier coup dur
ah ça c'est une histoire dont j'aime
mieux pas parler d'en face a été l'un
des coins de ma fille on n'en parle pas
non dans les coups de soleil pâle
dernier coup de soleil je suis passé
récent j'étais à grasse et à quelques
temps
j'étais bien à fait bien bronzé oui mais
là le bronzage du riche
pourquoi le riche tu crois que les gars
qui travaillent sur le haut de son papa
lé là et coup de bol elle dénie coup de
bol c'est jamais sans arrêt ouais et je
veux pas faire chier les autres on n'est
pas d'être heureux vaut-il encore que
les autres ne le soit pas les siens
dernier coup de rein ben j'ai encore des
blues ça je peux pas alors les coups de
blues ça fait partie c'est où tous les
jours pendant un moment un moment tous
les jours comme il faut a par sa
dépendance est il mort des périodes bien
des périodes où c'est cool ça vraiment
le blues ah oui et puis d'autres où ça
tombe sur la gueule comme ça mais
heureusement je suis bien entouré je
bosse le boulot c'est merveilleux ton
père qui l'avait dit ça il m'avait dit
tu ne trouveras que deux choses dans la
vie que deux choses valables c'est le
travail l'amour et tu peux pas trouver
autre chose a beau tourner comme tu veux
l'amour sous toutes ses formes
maternelle filiales
amour amour bien sûr avant tout et puis
le boulot la joie de travailler la joie
d'en avoir les fruits et qu'à ton père
tu as raison oui tout à fait on va quand
y'a le jingle parce qu'on met le titre
et tout ça il faut pas bouger parce que
sinon ça oblige à figer l'image donc
[Musique]
lumière
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est pas beau ça ça m'amuse
ouais c'est un truc pour compris comment
on écrit par les yeux en bouge pas et ça
évite de le figer l'image en régie je
veux dire ça gagne quand bon vous êtes
prête
oui bon alors dernier coup un votre
dernier coup dur
dernier coup dur des histoires de
personnel de par rapport à mes enfants
auxquels je tiens enfin qui sont mes
compagnons de vie quoi heureusement je
les ai donc voilà des choses de ma vie
j'étais malade
non non je dirais des corps léger pas en
parler par rapport à tanchoux et chez
l'épicier non mais dites et ce malgré sa
non le dernier coup de tête
téléphoner à un copain j'ai pas l'ami ne
sut pas 3 à 3 heures du mat non et oui
non mais je devrai dormi en lui disant
viens dit non non non non non non c'est
même pas un coup de tête
maintenant j'ai l'esprit mal tourné je
sais c'est un message à ses derniers
coups de foudre par rapport à un homme
mais malheureusement bon alors là ça
fait non ah bon
non ben on m'a lancé un appel à non
merci je vois comme un lâche non j'ai
pas confiance avec un numéro vert non
non on quand votre père vous engagez
vous dans chaque fois il me regarde les
éditions arrêtés lors plus c'est très
bien que j'aime bien avec maman aussi
ben ouais je discret tout ça mais mais
mais il va il dit louis tu comprends ça
ils n'aiment pas que je parle trop mais
maintenant il sait que je porte ce sens
mais il n'ya pas que c'est le gros mot
des trucs jusque là où jusque là elle
s'est bien comportée
alors là j'ai michèle cotta michèle
cotta nam-il de l'ami dieudonné thiery
franchement tu aimes bien le latic
d'agir voilà voilà
oui dans votre père qui était
journaliste sur leurs terres faut bien
le dire absolument être hétéro qui
étaient en afrique en justice à dakar
votre père si si je suis né je suis avec
à dakar gp meriem et je connais tous
deux vous ne vous avons pas vous
raconter d'histoires moi non dernier
coup de rein de rein devra donc l'amour
hier a alors assuré que j'espère que
monsieur célarié rassurer donc papa oui
papa merci papa parce que sa fille
donc c'était pas avec le dernier coup de
foudre s'était sali mais c'est pas un
coup de foudre
excusez moi je comprends non mais je les
aime beaucoup mais je sais coup de
foudre
ah oui d'accord sur le coup draft avec
un copain non ça sent bon ça deviendra
moi j'ai les coûts de foot je sais pas
trop parce que moi je tombe souvent mais
amoureuse pas forcément donc je veux
dire j'ai de la chance que je dis [ __ ]
non mais attention vous êtes mieux quand
vous faites pas attention à ce que vous
dites
non merci cet hôtel quatre jours quand
je parle des hommes ça se retourne
contre moi j'en ai pas une vie c'est
vrai classique et que les gens vous leur
posez quarante deux ans que je ne suis
pas mariée je ne suis pas installé dans
une vie mais c'est comme ça j'y peux
rien et puis ya plein d'autres femmes
comme ça et puis et puis crottes leur
donner plus mais bon voilà non mais
c'est non mais oui normal et les très
jeunes à 40,2 offre n'est pas garant de
mélinda bodin s'est plusieurs fois sur
le bistouri mais c'est tout donc après
on vous paie truc qui vous avez des
articles n'importe quoi cherchons pas
des trucs que c'est pour ça à ceyzériat
n'y a pas assez de temps pour en parler
pour que ce soit véritablement découdra
on va en rester là c'était hier soir oui
mais un coup de rein pour moi c'est de
l'amour c'est de la basse est passé du
serbe est non oui c'est de l'amour mais
l'amour pour moi le sexe et de l'amour
dedans sinon franchement ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout d'accord avis
aux amateurs n'ont été on a rallumé les
lumières devaient produire trop chaud la
route
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
ou bien tu as lu dernier coup ou dernier
coup de tête
dernier coup de tête le coup de tête
c'est en partant peut-être raid de la
télé ouais là des coups de poing mon
mari l'an dernier coup de poing c'est
plutôt une engueulade en voiture
ah ouais voilà avec larusso tiens
d'ailleurs je vais dire en parlant de
larusso va lancer un appel pour chercher
un jules tout ça on a lancé un appel
dans l'émission ça a super bien marché à
personne d'aller coup de rouge en
famille pour les 20 ans de ma soeur
c'est quand même temps c'était le 19
janvier pour la phase aller comment
votre sphère 4 1 m 80 je peux pas moi ça
me complexe du complexe du petit gros
rouge panique fuite depuis un peu cuit
twiggy
voit quand même j'ai dit à didier c'est
mon frère je suis mauvais de la bouche
rouge house au bon dernier coup de bluff
non je suis très mauvaise même au poker
je sais pas plus pas moins
oui et on amour tout ça vous ne le fait
jamais non là du pot ce goal non gaulle
est bizarre comme phrase bien les coups
de chapeau s'est conclue question ni
celle d'après mieux un jour ne pas
répondre à ces imbéciles
la suivante est mieux dernier coup de
rein vous avez dit qu'il était mieux
hier a dit d'oran je comprends pourquoi
ils perdent toujours dans les coups de
blues
on pourra lui même
à
[Musique]
ça bougeait ainsi ouais j'ai un peu
bouger le cul là tes trucs ça quand je
suis à votre émission vous l'avez fait
avec ses voiles ont refusé d'entrer tué
dernier coup à vous dernier coup dur
l'agencé pas ça n'a rien à voir le truc
adriana c'est pas ça can you please 3 de
slate for the girl plaisait pas à
traduire traduit très bien la nature la
peau d'un coup de tête bien ni en
voiture que pendant ma dernière voiture
c'est quoi ce faire la pub je les payais
quand même j'ai presque gratuite
une fois qu une voiture que le monde
entier connaît la fois la voiture
et c'est james bond en fait c'est une
berline un peu confortable c'est un beau
char bon ou mauvais coups de coeur
est-ce quelqu'un qui dit quelqu'un qui
dit qu' une berline et de seattle
d'ailleurs roger bové josée bouchard bon
dernier coup de coeur alors dernier coup
de coeur voilà qui me réussit pas mal
oui vous allez vous marier c'est
peut-être sa gonzesse attaques contre
ses kimberley et seattle déçu cette fois
c'est par là pour vous là bas
à suivre
dernier coup de bluff kimberley non on
rigole attend dernier coup de rein elle
est partie quelques semaines quelques
semaines et là c'est un petit peu à cran
puisqu'ils très bon ben alors avis aux
amatrices
il est chaud le garçon rallume bien
comme vous êtes boxeur vous comprendrez
qu'en face une interview dernier coup
personne ne bouge pendant un jogging
[Musique]
bien interview dernier coup votre
dernier coup dur j'en ai pas fait le
poids non je pourrais je pouvais perdu
la mémoire avec tout ça non ouais je
profiterai peut être un peu de voir
votre dernier coup de tête j'ai acheté
en fait non non vous n'êtes pas avec les
flics je me rappelle dans man she dont
16 heures
mais non rien du tout avant dernier coup
de coeur ma femme
et puis ma petite fille dans les coups
de poing dans les coups de poing or six
mois j'étais sur un ring dans la vie
quand je vois que bien non je crois que
c'était dans la vie dont vous c'était
beaucoup pensent think like home c'est
sympa c'est infectueuses dernier coup de
gueule il n'ya pas longtemps car y'a pas
longtemps on m'a enlevé ma voiture dans
une dans la fourrière mouvement voiture
et je suis la bonne et les mecs et tous
attaqué ce bacille son comble dernier
coup de rouge les coudes rouge bon à
l'âge avant de descendre
ouais ça je vous dis chapeau de chant
pas la pareille
dernier coup de poker à las vegas avec
quand vous jouez au poker à las vegas ou
qu'un dernier coup de feu non non non
jamais jamais non je t'ai riquet sa voix
la série qu'est un journal en même temps
dernier coup de blues d'un et coups de
blues
gros coup de blues quand j'ai perdu mon
argent ouais ça 10 millions ça énerve
dernier coup de rein pour longtemps hier
soir et ce matin
non je peux le temps et après me poser
avec une envie moi j'ai pas le temps
ouais on va vous faire une interview
dernier coup on est à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dernier coup dur le dernier coup dur la
candidature de balladur alors it will
avait déjà 3 et wii dernier coup de
coeur dernier coup de coeur pour
l'interview de françoise de panafieu
dans l ouais
qui dit quoi à elle dit beaucoup de
choses et l andi et sa famille andy
aussi il ya une chose qui m'a intéressé
c'est que sa soeur dit quand elle était
petite
il ya eu une grande famille cette
famille de sept frères et soeurs je
crois que sept ou huit
et elle était là glee n'est donc a été
la reine ouais et nous étions ses
esclaves et on lui apportait le savons
les choses sont donc ça va ça m'a
vraiment intéressé un peu peut-être
aussi inquiétée par où les mecs la can à
face ici tient bien
bien dernier coup de poing d'un
collaborateur qui je suis déjà manqué de
respect comme étant un peu un peu loin
de mes préoccupations politiques olza
dernier coup de folie
c'est sous le soutien permanent à jean
tiberi
ouais bien les coups de foudre
bernadette chirac bernadette chirac
devrait pas trop avec votre femme vous
mois dernier coup de gueule alors ça le
dernier que je viole ses permanents mais
cécilia c'était il ya une heure et demie
et les méchants troupes a400m a affolé
en trois un peu bled il faut savoir si
ces raspoutine richelieu sarah ont
napoléon iii physiquement franchement
c'est juste à côté des valeurs bancaires
et vous savez que ce gars est fair
livres sur napoléon iii jeu si l'avis de
beaucoup d'impôts 93 je sais bien que
c'était un grand emprunt voilà dernier
coup de pub
bassila ses entraînements elle vous aide
pas beaucoup mais non mais c'est bien
parce que je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui dit ce n'est pas un seul qui est
vrai c'est bien plus beau que la
sincérité c'est fini c'est fini d'en
découdre rouge
eh ben c'est ya deux heures oui vous
avez branché tout cas les faits la cave
de l'hôtel de ville non j'ai fait la
cave de l'hôtel de ville
ouais quand même cette bouteille 500
sénat 15 mille bouteilles quinze mille
bouteilles mesdames messieurs sur
l'hôtellerie
lepage de plus sans fin qui colle et ça
me surprend pas les coups de chapeau le
mans dernier coup de chapeau c'est celui
que j'ai donné à jean tiberi encore à sa
sortie de l'hôpital parce que ça
correspondait à ce moment là une
campagne de presse
extravagante et je trouve que le courage
qui est manifeste en permanence mérite
un vrai coup de chapeau
dernier coup de poker c'est celui qu'on
joue en ce moment c'est la partie en jeu
cependant c'est celui-là niveau de poker
et pour finir dernier coup de rein
avant-hier à 10 ans rallume
merci bernard bled alors vous avez
regardé le match mercredi soir caleb
bordeaux way for me l' énorme
un moment très rare c'est en progression
était géniale unique s'est jamais voir
dans le football alors à faire un truc
très compliqué là c'est une interview
dernier coup chanter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces moments
donc c'est me répondre en chantant je
vous dis par exemple dernier coup dur
c'est sympa à faire j'ai quand même du
mal à ça
jamais une fille qui était vraiment
jolie mais elle est partie avec mon
meilleur ami très bien c'est vrai en
plus en plus de sa soeur parce que c'est
pas loin de jouer
dernier coup de tête j'émets une autre
fille et au couvent elle j'ai tout donné
j'ai tout laissé j'ai tout laissé tomber
et puis maintenant je perds la tête bien
mes coups de quoi mon meilleur ami j'ai
fait le bois ensuite je lui mets une
droite dans sa gueule et il est tombé
il a fallu l'hospitaliser toujours
depuis que les musicales en tête
dernier coup de foudre j'ai rencontré
une autre fille mais celle là elle avait
un chemisier rose
elle voulait savoir quelle était mon âge
elle s'est trompée mais peu importe car
je crois qu'ils se passe quelque chose
entre nous ouais
michel lajoie rationnellement
de la question dany brillant dernier
coup droit
c'est tout à l'heure elle est engluée
et vous ai pas vus surnommé coup dans la
main ont valu moralement je vais soigner
laëtitia mais vous venez d'aix l'as
eupen ex vous êtes venus pour l'émission
en fait un ex prénom je devenu pourquoi
parler pour voir une amie ah bon et des
fois vous êtes retrouvé ici
quel est votre numéro de portable alors
comme votre livre vous dites que c'est
un coup de gueule on va vous faire une
interview dernier coup on ne bouge pas
dans la jungle
[Musique]
bien alors dernier coup de gueule
le dernier coup de gueule que j'ai
poussé c'était hier
contre qui c'était à propos de la sphère
rezala d'accord dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de tête qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un coup de tête j'ai un truc une
décision qu'on prend comme ça comme
cannes il veut rentrer avec les
massacres comme les maquis ventre avec
kad des coups de tête c'était il ya
il ya quinze jours quand j'ai acheté à
ma fille des double rideau un sac et on
ne sait pas si on regarde ma fille n'est
pas sage français françois braud seniors
une payante elle folle non elle voulait
un sac jouer dans une boutique avec elle
est là elle a 11 ans 1
et elle me dit papa ce sac me plaît et
coûter cher ça marche ça m'a fait chier
de dépenser une somme attendent pour
livrer son sac mais j'ai pas pu lui
refuser c'est bien c'est bien ça part
d'un bon sentiment
dernier coup de poing des coups de poing
c'est un vrai coup de poing ce téké
vengeance pas le dire mais pourquoi
lorsque le cac qui a fait une réflexion
des images en rendez vous dans un petit
fossé sans vraiment un moment présent au
dernier coup de pub
dernier coup de pub ceux ci se soient et
merci parce que ça vaut vraiment la
peine de dernier coup de foudre dans les
coups de foudre
oui de foudre qu'est ce qu'ils sont ma
famille de résistants sam harrisson en
plus c'est vrai moi vous êtes marrants
les mecs quand même en plus c'est ma
femme bon c'est bon mangez pas trois
mois
mégi 120 que moi c'est ma femme dernier
coup de bluff dernier coup de bluff tous
les jours hausse mardi après midi
ouais avait dit à l'audience mais à
l'audience fait et ba oui c'est votre
boulot vous en même temps au boulot
voilà dernier coup de barre bat tous les
jours
ouais c'est vrai attendu dernier coup de
rein pour finir hier soir bravo
bush pendant le génial interview dernier
coup geneviève de fontenay
vraiment on sait qu'on s'en va bien
comme disait fait
bien geneviève dernier coup dur répond
un sacré il va te dire dernier coup nous
tu fais ce que tu veux arrêter et
blindés non dernier coup dur très
sérieusement ce dernier coup dur
votre dernier coup dur moi mon oeil oui
ça fait très bien la voilà geneviève n'a
pas de coup dur dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de coeur battant les
imprimantes une petite appréhension je
vais rester c'est une session du forum
de deauville nous avons rappel ça fait
plaisir que nous avons vraiment apporter
un peu de joie à des enfants trisomiques
qui regardent et miss france avec
beaucoup d'émotion il y en a plein les
quatre armoires dernier coup de foudre
c'est vous cher chuck besoin
dernier coup de gueule voilà ce soit via
alors patrick dupont on va faire une
interview dernier nous battre dans le
final
[Musique]
non
dès que ma fille est plus là voilà je
constate que cette personne bouge merci
ça me fait très plaisir et je tiens
beaucoup à ça alors dernier coup c'est
facile dernier coup dur premier coup dur
en accident de voiture accident dernier
coup de coeur coups de coeur
adriana karembeu je comprends le dernier
dernier passait il ya 5 minutes ou
conçues j'avais bien dans les coups de
poing dernier coup de poing le procès
ouais là du coup de folie d'un coup de
folie
un très joli cadeau pour maman dernier
coup de foudre
dernier coup de foudre obama petit
partenaire maintenant landowski à huy
faible dans les coups de gueule dernier
coup de gueule je veux qu'on m'écoute
aux répétitions
ah oui je veux travailler alors il veut
répéter je trouve qu'on passe trop de
temps sur les autres passez sur moi on
vient les coups de bluff
le dernier coup de bluff quand est-ce
que je peux le fleuve tout le temps à
soufflage sauf ce soir vous pouvez pas
ici un dernier coup de barre dernier
coûte barbe c'était ce matin à 10h30
j'étais accroché à la barre ah oui
dernier
avec lui c'est normal dernier coup de
blues
dernier coup de blues oh là là bas il ya
deux jours je rentre à la maison crevé
il était minuit et demi je mets la radio
évidemment c'est barbara qui chante
l'aigle noir et celle du niagara
ça m'est arrivé avec le raf a vu en moi
[Applaudissements]
bien des coups de poker dernier coup de
poker je serais tenté de dire le procès
aussi parce qu'on sait jamais si on va
gagner ou perdre heureusement or là
c'est la justice qui a gagné donc temps
et attention patrick dupond dernier
couvre un dernier coup de rein
pas plus tard qu'avant-hier soir ça
s'est bien passé
génial votre dernier coup dur pour le
baril tous les jours aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va maintenant voilà
il durandet de vincennes vingt ans après
un pas une claque pas une forme de
cachets une affaire internationale
vraiment on se demande pourquoi on vous
le reproche également garder cet homme
un mec même pas amener les armes chez
moi j'ai un peu peur quand il a dit
votre dernier coup dur et qui m'a montré
heureusement qu'à des témoins le dernier
coup de tête paul peut-être le livre pas
mal votre dernier coup de coeur le
rwanda pourquoi parce que c'est un c'est
un pays qui voue d'abord il ya eu 3
millions de morts je pense en quelques
temps et ça a été la plus grande
manipulation historique où on a fait
croire qu'un qu'une ethnie avaient
massacré une autre ethnie alors s non
celle inverse dans les coups de poing la
semaine dernière avec qui le soir non
mais ça c'est une affaire privée
voilà c'est ça le rendait encore non non
non on s'est mis non il me regardait pas
quand vous parlez de coups de poing des
coups de tête ils m'inquiètent
capitelles d'aller coup de foudre
dernier coup de foudre c'est difficile
ça vous n'êtes pas avec votre non pas
deux derniers coups de fouet non
voulais pas le dire non c'est normal ça
se garde un dernier coup de gueule il ya
une semaine avant le coup d'envoi
non non avec mon équipe on aura un
problème africain et une mission à
l'extérieur parce que je crois que quand
on a on est manager dans le privé on a
une organisation civile
mais quand même à caractère militaire
est le chef qui garde une vieille notion
peut-être ça c'est important pour vous
qui voulez greffer des choses pour moi
le chef c'est celui qui crie le plus
fort qui tape le plus fort et c'est
celui qui se fait respecter non mais ça
va avec le côté également intellectuelle
mais sur le terrain ça se passe comme ça
mais armillaire sa suis sûr mais non
mais non mais je je pense c'est pour
vous at on déjà pour vous baril clc1
patinage history je voudrais vous dire
aussi baril si je voudrais vous dire
quand même que le courage moral
beaucoup d'hommes politiques que l'on
mais moi le courage moral va avec le
courage physique 1 et certains ont
beaucoup de courage moral mais de
courage physique il n'y a pas grand
chose ça bête et sega ou de vous devez
intervenir vous devez greffer une puce
de téléphone et que beaucoup les échos
un pentium de courage physique est ce
que je serais un autre monde
je pourrais simplement diable ne sait
pas c'est que c'est un personnage
historique après mon capitaine
mais ce qui était un personnage
historique ce je trouve que je ne doute
pas de votre courage physique puisque je
connais un petit peu quand même votre
carrière
mais vous avez le sans doute l'âge
venant intégrer de du maintien de
l'ordre tout ce qui est pire c'est pas
la seule chose que j'ai intégré
c'est à dire l'idée est justement de la
force appliquée la loi
l'idée que grosso modo vous êtes là en
position de supérieur c'est non pas du
tout quoi non je voudrais qu'il soit
vraiment né nombreux il ya des dames qui
sont ici le premier problème qu'est ce
que vous voulez tous vous voulez tous
cas sécurité voulaient sortir tranquille
voulait vivre tranquillement
vous aimez pas la sécurité vous avez
retrouvé votre voiture le spa vérifiant
vous voulez harry leur des ventes
message politique mais tout le monde
veut ça aujourd'hui mais un endroit
qu'elle a pris on peut d'abord l'on veut
nous faire oublier que la séance or sans
ce soir le regretter en motive votre
portefeuille vous allez dire merci non
j'appellerais la police dans sept
métiers vous accueillir dans une loge
après la police républicaine qui a
hausse mais je suis fière de voir
monsieur barils
et je trouve terrible
et c'est intéressant discussions on a
besoin non mais je trouve ça formidable
je croyais qu aujourd'hui la police
était définitivement républicaine
qu'elle comprenait que pour faire
appliquer la loi il faut l'appliquer à
soi-même monsieur barry vous n'avez pas
changé depuis 1968 je ne m'avoue avec
les pavés est en train de mettre le feu
aux voitures
alors que nous on veut des campagnes
tranquille on veut que les enfants
aillent à l'école
on veut qu'ils aient pas de pédophiles
n'ont pu ni sur les réseaux internet et
c'est ce que demandent tous les gens
bien mes coups de rouge ou de rejet
année coup de rouge qui comprend pas
question que de rouge
ouais je bois pas je ne fume pas jamais
bu jamais fumé avancer comme ça alors
mais je tire bien servir dernier coup de
bluff rbia y monte mais c'est terrible
parce que je fais un dernier coup de
fusil secret défense dans les coups de
blues ea n'a pas jamais de coup de blues
non c'est formidable jacques nom des
gens quand jamais de coup de blues
c'est pas moi je peux pas répondre parce
que chaque fois
le fait d'être fliqué sans arrêt comme
ça moi je trouve ça insupportable
j'aime pas la police quoi moi c'est
comme ça c'est la vie
ses fans avides you parce que j'aime
j'aime pas non plus les gangsters
j'aime créé non plus les mafiosi génial
en plus tout ça mais y'a un moment donné
où il ya collision qu'il ya collusion
plutôt que collision il ya collision
avec moi en tout cas j'ai jamais pu
appeler les flics quand j'avais à régler
un problème j'ai été voir le mec j'ai
parlé si c'était vraiment grave
ils sont jamais déplacés jamais et la
fois que je me suis trouvé dans des
commissariats en garde à vue où tout
j'ai vu des choses atroces et
dégueulasse mais profondément sous le
coup de la loi avec des gens qui étaient
sous le couvert de l'ordre de leurs
képis ray des tas de choses humiliantes
profondément salle quand on était avec
l'histoire du dallas il y avait 50 cars
de flics des gens comme vous pas des
clés les gendarmes correct d'accord poli
propre sur eux et on les paye c'est nous
qui les payons quoi et un moment donné
j'ai demandé un flic quand j'étais en
garde à vue je vais dit mais vous n'êtes
pas gardiens de la paix une non monsieur
je suis fonctionnaire de police attend
c'est quoi ça gardiens de la paix pour
moi ça voulait dire quelque chose mais
fonctionnaires de police va te faire
voir
va te faire voir
alan tieger
[Musique]
j'ai attendu la fin du dernier coup
alors derniers coups de pédales c'était
quand les derniers coups vraiment bas
c'était hier ah ouais vous entraîner
tous mes sabots c'était bien ah oui au
fait combien de kilomètres par jour
oui des jours où je fais pas grand enfin
une heure de piste c'est très fatigant
par exemple donc
quand je fais une heure de piste je fais
un entraînement soutenu et n'ont eu en
fait 45 km vous oui non pas tous les
jours en gros quoi je pense qu'on les
met dans le bain co va faire beaucoup
plus mais bon jouer hier je me suis
baladée 2h quadri core et quand ils
débarquent ils attendent l'audition le
noir et or
dernier coup dur les contrôles 1,13
emmerder par des contrôles un dernier
coup de foudre bien et coup de foudre
votre mari il ya longtemps quand même là
ouais à mais je parlais je ne cherchais
pas à vous cherchez pas cherchez pas
dans ce sens là
non non c'est un coup de foudre de
quelque chose qui m'a plu c'est en force
que vous pensiez pas un mec en fait vous
êtes pur c'est bien dernier coup de
gueule
vous êtes un peu râler les réputations
là moi je trouve charmante mais on
m'avait dit elle un peu râleur l'avenir
non dernier coup de gueule bar au
téléphone oui mais contre qui quand tous
ces gens qui vous répondent de façon un
personnel qui peuvent pas que il regarde
sur l'ordinateur on entend les
techniques comme ça et puis qu ils sont
à trois milieux de 2,20 quoi enfin bon
c'est pire rien n'avance quoi on a des
répondeurs et puis on attend puis on
recommence on accroche de concret
quelques moyens concrets
je suis pas des réservations d
tgv les attentes de co2 société dernier
coup de fil bien des coups de fil bien
vu qu'il y avait eu un dernier coup de
fil me souviens c'est mon neveu pur et
dur que j'arrivais à paris abandonne
donne un coup de rouge dernier coup de
rouge
oui s'il n'ya pas très longtemps ça
c'est pas tous les jours quoi ah oui
d'en découdre rouge c'était il ya
quelques jours
ah oui bouvet pas du vin tous les jours
non dernier coup de bluff
là maintenant sur le pinard à nos
derniers coups de blues dernier coup de
blues
yeah yeah pourquoi air inter à l'eau
découdra oui il ya aussi la vie sexuelle
des grands sportifs
sûrement la mesure commission
or m
ge précise de foudre à bord dont jaillit
précise le cuivre a quand même à cette
échelle aux coudres a répondu si
spontanément via sa bon sprinter maine
d'angers ce prix pondu saluent bien
alors avant de passer mon invité suivant
un petit email de sylvia de bologne qui
émeut dit la semaine dernière vous avez
refusé de faire dix secondes de silence
pour les suisses est ce que vous seriez
prêt à le faire pour les italiennes
oui c'est pourquoi les faits pour les
italiens mais si tu allais j'aime
beaucoup les italiennes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme vous l'avez les jeux ses amis mais
je sais et demi bon c'est une interview
dernier coup j'adore j'adore absolument
pas ce qui m'attend non monsieur dernier
coup je vous demander par exemple
dernier coup de tête facile non c'est
pas facile un dernier coup de tête je
pensais qu est ce que j'ai fait à une
fringue une voiture une avec un mec non
tenues la danse énorme et facile c'est
prendre le temps pour recevoir à
l'évidence quartet au stand et la santé
les issues de 7 % par la truck j'avais
acheté je sais pas moi ce que tu as
mangé un truc que quelque chose
bah j'ai vu un très bon whisky un arrêt
tout une épilation social en point
d'interrogation
je disais je retrouve des coûts tu as
tiré l'avait coupé les cheveux tout ça
[Applaudissements]
c'était bien là et c'était 3 heures du
mat et je trouvais que c'était un
soulagement bienvenu et donc j'aime être
entendu et tu avais vu non un truc à lui
c'est van sant est génial c'est à dire
que de temps en temps vous prenez j'ai
pas une cuite mais vous oubliez pas mal
et elle vous explique le lendemain matin
je suis comme neuf
oui vous êtes bien la seule personne que
je connais qui énerve après une cuite
mois et on attend donc là vous venez de
répondre à la première question c'est un
dernier coup de tête vous êtes coupé les
cheveux
donc on peut passer tranquillement la
deuxième dernier coup de coeur vous êtes
un cadeau olivier non un seul nom à mon
avis c'est penser à mon avis il joue
dans le gaz at her own stunts dernier
coup de foudre rivière
[Musique]
tu vois quoi
ouais bien et coups de fil dernier coup
de fil c'est et à aulas je suis pas dire
ça pour quoi
non parce qu'il va signer review du
dissident tan ça parce que j'ai dit dans
mon lit dit par olivier tu peux aller
chercher une bière dans le frigo
stockerait non non non bien les coups de
fil c'était c'était avec à la vous est
vanté un truc parce qu'il dit est juste
un c'est bien les gonzesses à monter
mais parce que c'est incroyable j'étais
dans she donc bah ouais avec mon
téléphone portable à côté toujours et je
fais toujours des trucs l'oreillette je
suis retombé dans le bain cet abominable
et je parle et m'appellent quelqu'un
chez les mecs ils sont beaux minable ah
oui comment ça va pratiquer peut-être
taille puis je vais olivier qui attend
c'est qui au téléphone
thibault c'est un copain s'est énervé et
voilà qu'ils sont jaloux mais oui c'est
normal quand on est une fille comme vous
qu'on y tiennent attendait c'est vrai
que des choses
dernier coup de rouge c'est quoi que
deux roues du var au jo du 20 non je
peux pas parce que j'ai les dents très
pour eux pour eux et donc si je bois du
vin riche donc j'avais le temps pour eux
cécile but viarouge elles deviennent
rouges
la crise a coûté dix minutes buvez du
vin blanc c'est ce que je fais n'est pas
seul
j'étais à courchevel il ya deux semaines
et une vie d'enfer olivier tu allais
faire les soirées un peu mondaine et moi
je prie j'ai pris une bouteille de vin
rouge magnifique avec une assiette de
fromage comme ça et ça et la télévision
fantastique les dents vries tout seul
c'est vraiment moi je pense quand même
que les pales
dernier coup de soleil il ya très
longtemps
tu me vois plus le soleil je mets de
l'autobronzant parce que le soleil ça me
fait dit vous voyez là oui regarde pas
c'est là où j'oublie de m dos de l'écran
tout âge
et là il ya quelques voilà alors que là
et là y'a rien mais là elle a pris le
sommet mais elle l'a gardé quand même
c'est gentil ça une chanson ça c'est une
chanson ça c'est une chanson est la paix
de soleil c'est de la garder c'est le
prochain album je suis sûr tu vas le
faire je te connais avec la face b au
toit majorettes
cette mesure est issu m on attend y est
tombé amoureux j'adore occupera tout
fromage tout ça a déjà fait un point
commun ouais on aime le fromage et le
bain japon mal dernier coup de blues au
tout le temps mais bon tout le temps
j'arrive à dormir le soir et donc je
suis insomniaque et donc que ça ça les
plus hardis sont figés mais ça développe
le fanta et nuit hallucinante
donc quand on est obligé de se lever
alors qu'on adore mes trois ans on
aurait voulu dormir 8
si dur matin c'est très très dur mais
n'arrivait pas à dormir dieu et des
choses qui tombent dans ma tête et je
n'arrive pas je
voulait pas prendre de somnifères vous
êtes comprends pas vous en prenez on
prend mais le matin on n'est pas bien
non plus mallet des trucs nouveaux
maintenant dix ans que trois heures dans
ton corps donc c'est bon ce qui n'arrive
pas à s'endormir
c'est pas pour ceux qui se réveillent la
nuit donc je prends cela mais c'est vrai
que comme tout le monde j'ai c'est de ne
pas en prend tous les soirs mais je sens
qu'on s'en va arriver je me dis ce soir
je sens que ça devient après on focalise
donc voilà à vous avez eu la même chose
non mais je vous comprends tellement
bien un nom déjà je suis en parfaite
empathie avec une la dernière question
rituelle alice evans dernier coup de
rein et à sète il ya sept ans étant
[Applaudissements]
heureusement fiori est là pour traduire
merci quatre à six à dix jours les jours
tu vas dernier coup de bluff la fête
bouillon dernier cobra je suis à londres
depuis bouillon avant mais c'est vrai
que j'arrive que ce matin au la la la la
la la la la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur coups de coeur c'est chez moi
maman retour et ce que j'ai fait c'est
vraiment ça
ah ouais j'ai regardé beaucoup et vous
voilà dans les coups de poing dans les
coups de poing là je pense je peux pas
dire coup de poing c'est ce que j'ai vu
ici c'est une luge en plus parce que si
c'est vrai alors c'est vraiment un
accident c'est ça bien de norbourg
people anaky vérifier son père dans les
coups de foudre d'aller coup de foudre
dans les coups de foudre ces tensions à
ce que vous dites ou non vous inquiétez
pas dans les coups de foudre belle
écoute route jcc méfie quoi il faut que
je suis j'ai ma fille qu'il ya quatre
ans des fois me fais moi rhône est grave
coiffer brown et moi et la maman quad et
dans l'est on a un coup de foudre non
dit j'ai envie de des fois quand on
embarque à l'école j'ai envie que ça te
revient si leur vie en 4e revient pour
virement l'année va chercher la bouffe
est quoi un dernier coup de rouge d'en
découdre où ça fait trois ans que ça
vous avez arrêté de boire
oui mais quoi que l'irlande pouvait plus
que je suis je suis je pense que je suis
devenu un petit peu méchant parce que
quand on boit beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
à un moment où les nerfs le joker vous
l'avez déjà il faut savoir il faut
savoir vous l'avez dit khaled bien les
coups de bluff
là maintenant là maintenant voilà je
suis bluffé la dernier coup de blues
dernier christophe dard et coups de
blues dans les coups de blues
passé récent vous avez un mauvais un
coup de blues d'un coup de blues
quand on tape à la porte a lieu ici pour
les aime pas la wii vous donner un
conseil à tous les jeunes chanteurs
ayant vous dit payez vos impôts
non mais c'est vrai mais quand on trouve
que déjà pour leur donne des chats kaki
qui reviennent et après tout ajoute des
majorations d'assez bien qu'il va
manquer c'est après is it on va lui
c'est ça c'est vos dernières questions
dernier coup de rein lui chier
[Musique]
bien dernier coup de tête à partir en
belgique comme ça moi je rentre dans
c'était comme un pari non plus mais
enfin bon ça fait bizarre quand même 2 2
kiko une ville de loin en belgique loin
loin loin à transformer de toulouse luan
tous les soucis et je lève ils furent
dernier coup de coeur il ya 11 ans quand
même en jeu et de ma femme donc c'est le
dernier vrai coup de coeur
après on a des coups de coeur
ponctuelles jours des gens sur des
chaussures des événements le vrai
dernier coup de coeur qui dure c'est
frédéric cette heure toujours away plus
fort la connaît c'est la même toujours
aller dans les coups de poing dans les
coûts de projet de faire un jeu t'avouer
un truc c'était à l'époque où je faisais
était lésée braille toi tu te souviens
j'étais arrivé avec la gueule
complètement déformés je m'étais fait
déchirer la tronche dans une bagarre et
tout je t'avais dit que je m'étais fait
choper dans métro avec ma femme j'ai
vraiment et que j'avais voulu défendre
ma femme parce que j'avais posé de dire
la vérité je peux te le dire maintenant
en fait j'étais allé dans une soirée les
potes et ça avait terminé en baston
générale les mecs avaient dit du mal de
moi et tu m'avais défendu mais c'est ça
voilà
c'est vachement rennais mais vachement
en doublettes ma vie n'est pas question
maintenant tu fais ce métier il pas
question d'une bagarre qui va être dit
voyons donc je vais pas aux hits avouer
que donc je redis je faisais tu m'avais
pas cru faute à gruissan lendemain
croire ce que j'en dis ah là j'arrive à
la figure 69
vous pouvez me poser la question que
vous voulez la question est question que
vous avez le choix consensuel géant une
question que tous les spectateurs se
pose mode être choses qui peuvent se
poser quand il regarde combien tu as de
nuces avec les années et c'est ça change
c'est télé 7jours ça nous amuse non non
acheter a vraiment vraiment vraiment 52
enfants dont 56 judy pose une question
et thierry 06 toujours emmerdé avec ces
trucs là la question j'aimerais tourner
vous avez une idée vous qui tiens
quelqu'un peut me fils aîné des as que
t'aime bien est ce que tu aimes toujours
les nuits blanches
oui mais maintenant quand chez les
blanches c'est pour travailler c'est
plus pour sortir ce que tu te fout de
notre gueule un peu
dernier coup de foudre abbas et le we
dernier coup de foudre bâtir le scénario
de la vérité de ce conflit paix avant de
le recevoir vraiment une suite enseigne
on obligé on a un devoir y ait de ce
film parce qu'on lui doit tant et d'eau
puis on l'a terminé on sait tous appelés
pour la trouver vraiment à ma dernier
coup de gueule hier dont je vous ai
assez je passais soupe au lait je gueule
beaucoup souhaiteraient coléreuse jetons
et poussèrent dans une radio
ils m'ont fait chier j'ai quitté le
plateau et en plus j'ai eu tort traîné
toute l'équipe jardy venu en classe qui
sont tous venus dernier coup de bluff
dernier coup de bluff c'est pour avoir
un rôle dans un film j'ai fait croire à
lambert wilson que j'étais engagé dans
le même film que lui
ouais parce que je n'arrivais pas à
rencontrer la médiatrice brigitte roy et
priori ne voulait pas de moi et j'ai je
recroise lambert midi je joue dans le
film dit moi aussi
aussi génial il appelle à rio crise et
qui m'a appelé après m'a dit mettez ça
veut dire quoi tu joues pas dans mon
film gimat ça tient qu'à toi elle m'a
rencontrée elle m'a donné voilà il a
appris le poker avec la vérité un
dernier coup de barre en ce moment je
suis pour y casser avec toi d'abord
parce que ça fait un mois et demi que je
suis donc en tournée que frédéric
pourcel a pas pu y aller pas eu
l'occasion de venir à une vis à vis pas
à la fan bruno solo à la n10 les
sculpteurs l artiste elle a beaucoup de
travail en soi en belgique et la pole
temps elle préfère me rejoint demain au
[ __ ] c'est que j'ai la banane aulas
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas pour le
jingle
oh
bien c'est l'interview dernier coup de
quatre buts pour ça oui c'est ça bon
vous êtes prêt faudel de quoi bâtir une
interview dernier coup est parti dernier
coup dur mort de charles trenet c'est un
parent à vos derniers coups de tête
foot au foot je m'y arrête j'ai marqué
un but on cherche des gens qui
m'arrêtent et me le prendre offert ses
partisans si tu savais marquée des
charges des buts et c'est là encore je
cherche des buts je suis le meilleur
parti
navevo simplement ils marquent contre
leur camp allez dans le corner
ils ont ils cherchent des buteurs c'est
payé 300 millions dernier coup de coeur
alors des coups de coeur aussi un album
on peut dire qu'ils bah oui julien clerc
ah oui si j'étais elle est bien celle là
j'aime bien le fait mieux que toi faudel
on se concentre dernier coup de poing et
mouchan nous violons je ne sais pas
crédible quand je suis saturé une patate
ouais je sais pas j'ai jamais fait un
dernier coup de folie d'un coup de folie
je cherchais une porsche
j'ai acheté une maison à maintenant bien
dernier coup de foudre
coup de foudre séverine ferrer reis et
vous la regretter un peu savent en faire
un nom
dernier coup de fil coup de fil
j'ai demandé l'adresse de ton studio
ouais voilà voilà dernier coup de rouge
c'est un petrus 82 aulas à s'arranger
pognon avait est très souvent mais quand
ils boivent c'est du bon dans les coups
de bluff sang du christ dernier coup de
bluff
bon là j'ai dit ouais j'ai blessé
maman parce que je l'invité à manger un
couscous le dimanche et et je vais dire
au fait j'ai oublié j'ai inventé ce
moment je suis désolé coup de froid
coup de froid ici dans le studio parce
qu'ils calent il faut mettre de bulles
comme accusera qui vient aux césars avec
sa wii avec ton forfait
dernier coup de blues coup de blues
quand j'ai quitté séverine la tête
dernier coup de rein c'était hier
mais allez un petit garçon maintenant
[Applaudissements]
interview dernier coup
en ébauche baldinger
pendant les tinner
bien vu que j'ai un peu romane super
sage vous êtes très sage mais bon non
mais quand ma fille est pas là c'est
plus simple de pas bouger parce qu il
entraîne les autres en fait c'est comme
l école que des mecs qui entraîne les
autres
dernier coup dur tu le connais ouais
c'est quand serge est parti dans les
coups de bol les dix derniers coups de
tête
on ne sait pas en comptant les garçons
en asie la wii ah oui c'est vrai où je
conviens importants du vietnam ou pas
pour toujours quand même moi je vais
tuer partir dans les baies d'halong avec
l' aventure chez l'habitant sxop remet
ça dans les coups de coeur aulas tel
courant dans les coups de poing sur lui
ah ouais bah oui ça se voit jamais le
mettais découvre ça m'est arrivé je lui
ai dit si tu continues à l'école comme
ça c'est coup de boule maintenant là
c'est pas un coup de poing ses coups de
boule dernier coup de foudre
serge dans les coups de gueule hier les
coups de fil mais lui l'année coup de
places mis des coups de blues
un dernier coup de mou c'était très
récemment et lâche en train de continuer
un petit coup de blues le dernier coup
de rein couvent ah oui c est pas là mais
c'est vrai nom mais c'est mais je sais
mais vous n'arrivez pas la remplacer
non non figée sais pas quoi chez mon
coeur et puis si mon coeur me dit
regarde bien les mecs qui voudra quand
même oui mais c'est pas mon problème
ou toujours une sainte
oh non pas du tout je suis loin d'être
une simple ça c'est clair
mais bon je vous dis ce qui se passe
bien la dialyse à moyen terme du dernier
coup vous êtes prête pour les mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
naji un dernier coup dur nami coup dur
avec mon fils ce matin qu'est ce qu'il a
fait on s'est cogné la tête donnait avec
lui ouais t'as quel âge je comptais
dormi avec ma femme dort toujours avec
mon fils pour ça je me renseigne
il a 18 ans non mais ça va il a deux ans
et papa il n'est pas et pas un peu
vénère ne pas dormir avec maman non non
il sympa la question se pose pas voilà
mon avis est une gaffe c'est pour savoir
c'est une ouverture ça n'a rien d'une
gueule dans les coups de coeur à mon
fils ah oui il ya eu depuis le fils il
prend peut-être beaucoup de place à la
fin il faut pas vous fixez trop sur ce
bébé non plus on n'a pas beaucoup quand
même
et j'ai la chance de l'avoir c'est
vraiment une force ça me procure
beaucoup dit et je vais recevoir des
emails moi c'est incroyable a dit mais
je dois je le vois pas bien ni dernier
coup de poing
non c'est lors du tournage de mon clip
en fait il y avait le champion d'europe
de kung fu et voilà on a fait des
petites allées d'accord ces
professionnels d'aller coup de foudre
vernet coup de foudre avant cette fois
hier soir
ah bon milledge à kathryn peale
bischwiller et vous connaissez catherine
barba très bien très bien dans les coups
de gueule et coups de gueule
ah oui avec la directrice de la crèche
de vos fils parce que j'ai récupéré mon
fils avec une morsure à 100 et ça m'a
pas plu quoi je suis normal la gelée
oui par un autre bébé enfin un autre
enfant quoi des morsures il faut faire
plus d'enfants avec pas mal de
références c'est pas normal parce qu'on
a bien fait d'aller coup de fil fils
d'aller le coup de rouge n'ont jamais
jamais est musulmane est totalement
dernier j'ai pas le droit c'est déjà
leader je sais c'est bien cette religion
musulmane d'ailleurs sur le droit de
fumer des pétards non bâchés sais pas je
jamais essayé non plus non mais si elle
sait déjà que je revis belgique mais sa
mission ne passe pas mais tu fume
beaucoup afin de diriger deux ans
d'accord mais je veux dire dans les
vapes assumer sont enfin c'est pas bien
qu'à son pack et ia ils sont sont joints
avec lui voilà nous dit diamant sur la
dent ah bon pourquoi si jolie dans les
coups de soleil et en même temps il ya
longtemps dans les coups de bol 1 250
mètres carrés à 3000 francs par mois
voyez-les ou non je rigole ribéry n'est
pas passé oui vous là nous et non non
pas de ça chez nous ça se fait pas avec
vannes ou et les genres en plus
d'appartements ont inquiété dans le
comité de soutien de la noce qui est
très drôle c'est le jour nous a tous
réunis pour nous remercier il a dit et
surtout ne comptait absolument pas sur
moi pour obtenir quoi que ce soit nous a
très très bien et qu'il a fait un petit
gerra fait dans mon bureau
j'espère qu'il part en titres
j'espère qu'il le pense vraiment avec
évidemment que l'on est remercié
monsieur crieu très locale croit ouais
bah oui je crois qu'il l'a dit qu'il est
un fait mais c'est sympa c'est mignon ah
merde il est nul
là les coups de blues hier soir que ce
qui s'est passé je le fais les soupçonne
le soir à cannes is by any ci fait dodo
quand même il a une pensée toute seule
alors la question cruciale dans les
poudres à ce matin la salle de gym
parce que je fais beaucoup de sport je
m'entraîne énormément
et alors comme j'ai eu pas mal de coups
durs la une porto rico il ya eu roissy
on va vous faire l'interview dernier
coup on ne bouge pas pendant les ting à
[Musique]
gauche pendant le génial c'est une robe
grise et moi un dernier coup dur pour
touré comme porto rico dans les coups de
foudre
il ya longtemps c'est avec apple 4,4 au
sénat faire quitter dans les coups de
gueule ses fidèles des coups de fil
dernier coup de fil c'était pas le
courrier picard tout à l'heure à
l'aéroport troisième aéroport qui
veulent installer croyable c'est lui qui
dirigeait le pays j'aime bien je
voudrais tuerait parce que changerait
tellement de choses ah bon feriez quoi
par exemple si vous étiez premier
ministre la première décision vous
prendriez geneviève déjà je serai plus
là bourse qui mènerait le monde
ah oui ça déjà reste que c'est l'argent
qui mène le monde en ce moment et moi je
suis révolté de voir de plus en plus de
misère de ce qui me révolte aussi c'est
sophie thalmann quand je pense que le
gagner des fois dans une en une heure ce
que les pauvres caissières des grandes
surfaces gagne en un mois et moi je
trouve que devrait avoir honte de dire
des choses comme ça pour pour simplement
faire dédicacer à sourire vous êtes pour
la taxe tobin januvia la taxe tobin pour
nos normes euro 5
ça me dit ça me hérisse les poils de
penser à lyon juste quand tu t'habitues
un nouveau front à bussy
[Applaudissements]
bien dernier coup de rouge non avec
s'était pas je n'emprunte pas ton dans
les coups de bluff
elle a dit je paye souvent geneviève oui
qu'est-ce qui ronge les robes après
james qui remet tout dans des mois une
fois que c'est fini après quelqu'un
remballe qu'est ce qui m'emballe d'image
dsk parce qu est ce qui conduit pourvu
que j'ai encore la santé beaucoup aimé
geneviève vous êtes une star je ferai
moi jolie dernier coup de chapeau
[Musique]
[Rires]
ils entendaient bien toutes les deux
j'entends bien victoire et oui c'est ça
qui est bizarre c'est moche mais c'est
vrai qu'à caractéristiques soudée a
coûté le cannet des méchants pas beaux
endroits
jamais jamais élevé on se concentre à
dernier coup de rein à joker
non commandes bien encore un petit
interlude dernier couet lannes vous êtes
prête en la bouche pendant les tonga en
la bouche par dans le qinghai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup dur dernier coup dur c'est
d'avoir d'avoir vu moyens des animaux
dernier coup de tête
d'avoir refusé un concert uniquement
parce que le répertoire n'était pas moi
dans les coups de coeur le dernier
concert parce que chaque fois dans un
conseil à une communication émotionnelle
qui s'établit et 1
c'est ça qui sauvent en fait bien des
coups de poing pas encore dans les coups
de folie tout doux dans les coups de
foudre
la france entière est suspendu a volé la
franchise amoureuse de vous et veut
savoir
non non non en fait le dernier coup de
foudre c'était pour une oeuvre way we
dans les coups de gueule
avec trois maisons de disques l'année
dernière un dernier coup de pub ici dans
les coups de fil cette nuit à quai l
homme que j'aime bien les coudes rouge
mais coup de rouge
non je n'aime pas trop le vin est bon
buvez quoi vélo c'est un reagan contre
les quoi comme drogue
ma drogue c'est le cancer c'est
l'adrénaline des coups de soleil
il ya trop longtemps et 6 ans ah ouais
ouais cet été vous parlez un peu au
soleil quand même bien pourquoi je n'ai
pas le temps non autant ça se prend
remarquez on a tous 24 heures dans la
journée donc c'est hypocrite de dire non
l'été vous pourriez partir un petit peu
on peut vous accorder side merci non
mais c'est vrai dernier coup de barre le
mois dernier à paris ouais ouais voilà
incapable de bouger c'est ma miss paris
avait annulé les concerts à ce moment là
non je vous ai commencé
vous allez voir à sa maman vous avez
animé les émissions de télévision mais
pas des concerts dernier coup de chapeau
au prêtre de notre paroisse dans des
coups de froid
l'indifférence dans les coups de blues
moi j'ai le blues en avance oui ah bon
j'ai le blues pour tout ce qui ne s'est
pas encore produit d'en découdre 1
il n'y a pas si longtemps il ya une
semaine mais j'ai deux boxeurs donc on
va faire une interview dernier co c'est
normal bush
dans le qinghai on ne bouge pas pendant
le tigre
brian dernier coup de tête là ce soir
ouais dernier coup de coeur le spot que
je viens de faire
ouais pour l'éducation nationale pour le
respect pour les jeunes c'est vrai
dernier coup de poing le 8 octobre à
paris pendant et depuis il n'y a pas eu
de coup de poing non juste le ring comme
génie sur le 3e dans les coups de folie
monté sur un ring ouais ouais parce que
c'est une folie dernier coup de foudre
ont d'abord un joker joker un joker donc
c'est de la personne à côté qui répond
c'est la loi ici
je sais jean mon dernier coup de foot
vous êtes venir dans votre émission
mais si j'avais tellement peur comme
annonce tout va bien de thon faisait
enfin rencontrer très bien et toi les
coups de foudre et le dit busch a nantes
on l'a dit c'est bizarre oui c'est
bizarre très bizarre se disent assez
bien bien bien des coups de gueule de
jean la circulation ah bon ouais ben
mahdi de passer gm au passé
concernant guilad sujets discutés moi
j'étais je dis respect monsieur l'agent
rester bien placé pour dire sa dernière
prise de sang avant le combat
on va faire une interview dernier qu on
a beau chemin
avec dunga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très bien as tu peux bouger la whey
dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur tourcoing ouais ouais j'aime bien
cette ville cheval moi c'est jean pascal
je trouve que c'est un garçon qui a
plein de talent et d'émotion
[Applaudissements]
ouais dernier coup de poing dans les
coupes point j'ai vu chez qui le nul
mais ta coupe point un mec là pendant un
match
ouais j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire mois
à bouli dans les loges qui m'énerve avec
son casque l'année coup de folie un
aspirateur 1500 arrêté a été vraiment de
la tude ainsi peut-être des filtres à
café que j'étais bien j'ai claqué au
moins dans les sandales deux sont
peut-être en euros ouais ça fait ça à
peu près dernier coup de foudre
je me positionne moment pour mais
j'avais été chercher mon courrier chez
moi et en fait dans la cage d'escalier
donc je descends et j'ai croisé ma mère
et on s'est regardé tout ça tu vois
voilà j'ai un peu craqué ça s'est
arrangé avec ta mère tu vois la coque
dernier coup de gueule faire des coups
de gueule b à l'aspirateur
après j'ai engueulé que le dernier coup
de pub mais c'était avant d'aspirateur
ah non moi c'est quand j'ai dit omar
tiens regarde la bague et une crêpe au
fromage qui t'appelle
j'avais tout sourire j'ai appelé le mec
pour qu'il fasse marcher l'aspirateur
d'acteurs non moi c'est j'ai appelé mon
père pour lui expliquer par notamment à
un dernier coup de roue je te demande
pas tu vois pas toi non non jamais
jamais ah non moi je trouve que sans
alcool la fête est plus folle tiens
c'est ma devise
ah ouais c'est bien dernier coup de
soleil c'est pas marrant c'est bien de
dire si c'est bien de le dire
j'ai tenté et c'est vraiment toi moi
c'est quand je me lève le matin que je
tourne la tête et qu'est-ce qu'il
évoquait ce qui les musées français
ce dernier coup de bol et petit déjeuner
au mas du risque dernier coup de mou ce
dernier coup de blues
c'est là maintenant parce que je sais
qu'on n'ira jamais chez fogiel quoi
arrêt dernier cobra découdra il ya deux
ans j'ai donné un rat un mec
[Applaudissements]
interview d'un
[Musique]
dernier coup de botte dernier coup de
tête il ya trente secondes je prenne la
tête contre le mur
l'un des coups de coeur je pense que
j'ai mis tout le temps je tombe raide
dingue de plein de choses de toujours à
leur écoute poing coups de poing
huissier venu hier matin chez les athées
dans les coups de foudre
ak je veux faire un trip bien les
coutumes avec staller etienne bien deux
minutes avant
l'indicateur est touchée dit franchement
maintenant vous arrêtez d'avoir peur
d'en découdre rouge bat aussi à l'aller
coup de soleil
jamais je prends le soleil ne bronze pas
j'ai un jour pour aller faire des photos
de nu la dent lui là que le père de mes
enfants
on est parti très très long à l'île
maurice où ça bronze paraît-il j'étais
comme ça les les coups de soleil
et puis je n'osais pas un gordon haff
est au max factor est en écoute blues il
ya tout le temps forcément
dans les coups de reins il ya longtemps
vous ne serez pas surprise la hausse
aussi je vous finissez abus dernier coup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à vous me décevez de plus en plus
franchement assez bien aller là qui
bouge pas par le jingle ça c'est très
bien mais garde son dernier coup de tête
mes chaussures dans les coups de coeur
mon nouveau chéri mais magnifique mardi
les grands il est moyen bruns les yeux
marron très mignon très gentil s'appelle
thierry sexuellement est ce qu'il est
comme tout les tirer au but et je ne
vous ai pas testé mon cher donc c'est
pas c'est vous qui avez pas voulu en
même temps alors
excusez moi alors voyez pas de la
malveillance mai dernier coup de poing
je sais pas j'ai mis un coup de poing
sur la table il ya pas très longtemps
non mais vraiment très fort membres m'a
fâché j'étais au téléphone on m'a bien
énervé et je pense par table des coups
de folie ça faisait longtemps que
j'étais pas sorti j'ai fait vraiment une
mega mega nuits blanches effet deux
jours non-stop son avenir donc voilà on
va dire c'est ça mon contrôle y passe
les coups de blues il ya une semaine
pourquoi j'ai pas des fois je me remets
un petit peu en question je suis face à
la couleur des cheveux dia non non non
j'ai je me remets en question des fois
je me demande je j'analyse un peu ma vie
je fais un peu le bilan de tout ça même
si je n'ai que 22 ans et des fois j'ai
des petits coups de cafard comme tout le
monde mais c est mon signe astrologique
qui veut ça aussi une balance son trait
voilà vous regrettez fabrice des fois
pas du tout à mon goût du jour puis de
médical en amour comme ça c'est où
j'aime et puis quand c'est fini je passe
à autre chose
d'ailleurs je profite de
ici pour dire qu'il faut arrêté de m'en
parler parce qu'il est avec une autre
femme et elle commence à en avoir marre
de moi d'accord donc faut plus parler
d'eux qui remercia chéri dernier coup de
boule coup de boule couchettes
ouais j'aime si jamais ça on imagine des
trucs en tête dans les coups de reins ça
c'est un discret bon pourquoi autant
entendu tout à l'heure
alors vu que vous êtes blessé robert
pirès vous comprendrez quand vous fasse
une interview dernier coup
[Applaudissements]
bien les coups de tête je suis pas
méchant donc presque pas dans le m way
dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur le dernier cadeau que j'ai pu
offrir à ma femme pour son anniversaire
c'est quoi c'est un c'est un collier en
forme de coeur un diamant un diamant
j'aurais dû épouser un footballeur moi
je suis quand dernier coup de folie il
montre cher oui oui quand même acquis
pour moi passer de l'air de bien des
coups de pub
bachand point les modèles et les fin du
mois c'est pas les fin du mois ne
disposions que tu prends un shampooing
pour un dernier coup de fil c'était un
ami pour savoir où j'allais manger ce
soir
ouais vous appelait encore hey les mecs
là maintenant ouais ouais j'suis en
relation et sylvain wiltord
qu'est ce qui dit sylvain non ça va ils
vont bien ouais il faut pas s'en
inquiéter un joueur tout le monde
s'inquiète le commandement est très
inquiet là commence à paniquer un peu et
qu'il faut il faut attendre simplement
pas temps de la finale tu crois non non
dernier coup de rouge je vois pas les
coups de bluff
là maintenant les bois là maintenant
dernier coup de bol la coupe dernier
coup de blues français légal d'ouverture
de la coupe du monde difficile c'était
quoi le score 1-0 pour le sénégal du
rosé pas su et gagnera qu'on fait
dernier coup de rein hier soir il a des
amis et tout ça non
bien alors que sept joueurs vous êtes
acteur de films d'action en même temps
un homme de coups on vient de le voir
tous ces êtres différentes activités et
avec ce film did you see donc
maintenant on va faire l'internaute
dernier coup
qu'est ce flambeur dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de tête partir en bateau ou
en grèce à cg ou en grèce dans toute la
gamme nikon au nom d'une vieille soir à
mykonos j'étais avec ma femme
l'abonnement coûte que ailleurs je t'ai
vu mais pareil qu'une femme peut couper
dernier coup de coeur mais se fait
bronzer 20 minutes sur le vent que j'ai
boîte et deux semaines je veux dire à
tous que jamais qu'on parle de sa
nouvelle que sur levante là bas alors
dernier coup de coeur à femme bien les
coups de gueule dernier coup de gueule
je suis quelqu'un d'extrêmement calme un
patient mais je suis pas un gueulard du
tout c'est à dire je m'adapte je te
ferai des dix derniers coups de beats et
là où partir je le ferai la mort sinon
il va il est grossier un dernier coup de
fil à leurs derniers coups de fil
vrai ou le vrai dernier coup de cutter
un dernier coup de fil à samuel et aux
producteurs de
janis et john pour savoir comment ça se
passait en avignon où ils sont en ce
moment et ça se passe bien et ça se
passe à salé bois il ya des gens sur les
marches d'escalier tout baigne c'est
génial dernier coup de rouge passé il ya
deux mois dernier coup de rouge était il
ya deux mois et demi dans les coups de
bluff
c'est la théorie sur le roulage enfin
dernier coup de soleil
j'adore j'adore le soleil de juin
présentent comme entité mais je me mets
jamais au soleil d'accord mais je mets
de la crème est ce que tu es en plus je
rougis donc c'est bizarre et un écran
total par exemple est quand même dans
même way et à l'ombre à l'ombre dernier
coup de bol dernier coup de bol d'avoir
rencontré samuel eto'o au niveau de ma
carrière au niveau de ma vie sophie dahl
et coups de blues bien écoute blauzac
ans quand je buvais beaucoup et que ces
refuges ça me faisait du mal à ma vie
ouais ils se mettaient les lélés les
cassettes de vingt cinq normales
[ __ ] j'aurais pas dû faire ce dernier
coup de cul non d'en découdre à entre
josiane un peu enfin
ma foi comme dernier coup droit gagnant
il ya quatre jours parce que je suis
arrivé il ya trois jours que tu fais ben
j'étais un week-end à part dont on
comprend
allez ce dernier coup de boule non mais
t'es pas de coup de boule mais enfin
bien les coups de tête coûtait tu
voulais dire bah je sais pas être là ce
soir par exemple
ouais c'est bien moi j'ai plutôt vers
les coups de pub c'est peut-être aussi
mais si on fait plaisir
dernier coup de tête ça serait de dents
partie avec philippe lellouche après
l'émission ça ce serait un sacré coup de
tête mais bon je te remercie pourquoi
coûtait tiennent non ça peut être un
coup de ça peut arriver à ben oui du
hasard mais c'est là qu'il a rencontré
vanessa déjà oui c'est vrai dernier coup
de poing dans une vitre j'étais énervé
ouais bon la terre cher rien elle était
là quoi dernier coup de folie j'ai pas
et faire cette pièce de théâtre
ouais voilà quoi m habillée comme ça je
m'habiller comme ça dernier coup de
folie
non pas trop non non non mettre des
porte jarretelles voilà ap ap ap ap le
jean qui veut dire non et demi pourrait
pour sincère voilà sinon ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas dit fais
attention à ce genre de truc juste et
passer en direct quelques années on
entend dire est qu'ils arrivent à le
signaler
je pense qu'il vaut mieux donc donc
voilà même temps c'est pas un coup de
folie je le fais régulièrement donc
quelques jours plus tôt continue d'en
parler quand même un peu mais c'est pas
mal ça c'est moi des gens c'est sur un
sujet
quand tu dis souvent c'est à dire je
suis en affaires comme ça pour le fun on
les porte jarretelles un père c'est plus
rare il fait froid dernier coup de
foudre alice a renié coup de foudre
amoureux amoureux s'étaient corps cité
il ya un nom aux seniors qui se
terminent tout ça dans les coups de
gueule dans le taxi qui m'a amené ici là
pourquoi il entendit l'audimat de karl
zéro et nous a pris la tête
pourquoi parce que ils voulaient pas
nous emmener là où on allait il voulait
aller ailleurs font penser non je vais
en espagne
coup de fil à votre assistante
ah ouais vous avez dit quoi ben c'est
tout va bien je suis dans le taxi
dernier coup de rouge abeilles à deux
énormes à voilà beaujolais tranquille
oui oui tu tires la chopine pour l'usap
à même de petites bouteilles d'ailleurs
c'est vrai oui parce que sans cela quand
même voilà vous pouvez faire l'amour
agen quand même bien sûr dernier coup de
bluff ou coup de bluff mais à bernard
murat voilà qui m'a engagé dans sa
pyramide du soleil ont pas de coups de
souris dans les coups de bol attention
ça se rapproche tous les jours dans les
coups de blues ont rarement
ah bon je te prendrai mon album
[Musique]
n'écoute que bahia ya quoi il ya 5
heures quoi ben oui quelques embardées
de la confondues non non nous on a mal
compris ses coûts plus qu'autre chose je
suis content de moi j'ai compris comment
qu'un j'ai une pensée invités jusque là
tu sais pas l'héroïne c'est que tu as
deux ans avant de rentrer en scène un
dernier coup de cul c'est quoi c'est ça
la question c'est quoi pour vous 1 1
dans les coups de cul c'est quoi pour
vous un dernier coup de cul voulais me
demander quand je les ai eus jouer ses
derniers coups de gueule
cet après midi vous allez voir mais
wimbée qui au bout quoi c'est quoi les
petites culottes parce qu'on n'a pas les
mêmes puisque c'est un coup de cul
en découdra musulmans des coups de cul
yann un prix d'honneur à coups de coeur
[Musique]
dernier coup de tête dernier coup de
tête dans mon dernier match de football
chez pas content à camp sara monde parce
que j'ai une sciatique en ce moment donc
sa femme ont bien joué au ballon bien
mes coups de coeur et coups de coeur
pour moi forme actuelle qui je viens
d'avoir un enfant la sciatique dont il
parlait ça vient de là aussi bien les
coups de poing ça devait être en même
temps que le coup de tête mais dernier
coup de folie
je me suis acheté un appartement ah
ouais quand même
étudiants pourront bien j'ai vécu 37 300
de liste humain qu on me donnait j'ai eu
l'occasion d'acheter un appart sa viande
est de faire et est où là je suis dans
le 9 2 c'est bien c'est plus chic and
docks 3,9
il ya les gens du 9-3 qui vont siffler
bien et c'est pas très loin tu prends
les ics et un flash était assemblée
après versailles après je ne sais pas
pour avoir peut-être peut-être dernier
coup de foudre
moi je te les dites à leurs jeux flash
c'est ma femme bien les coups de gueule
et coups de gueule je crois que c'est
écrit dans c'est mal barré
ouais dernier coup de fil
tout à l'heure on est potes là dans la
loge way pour lui dire je passe à ton
démission qu'est ce qu'il y en a à
[ __ ]
ils sont celles où on n'a pas l'occasion
de passer souvent la télé donc c'est ça
leur fait plaisir quand on est là dans
les coups de soleil
la dernière fois que je suis en vacances
je veux tu as vu le montant est pas très
bronzée donc mme wade il faut un rayon
de soleil cécile prêts directs
il ya plus de soleil dans le 9 2 que
dans les rangs ça dépend de l'altitude à
la kryte habite berne et coup de bol les
coups de gueule je suis rentré deuxième
là au top a fait passer d'un petit coup
de barre dans les coups de blues
j'ai perdu les 10 villes ça doit être
celui-là dernier coup de rein à ya pas
longtemps non plus mais malgré la
sciatique on se débrouille
[Musique]